hey what's up guys it's Marcus Brownlee
here from mkbhd and welcome to another
HD hardware video in which I will be
showing you why rap cyl is the number
one anti scratch protection system for
your device so let's get right into this
so right off the bat you guys are
hearing I'm very positive about Repsol
and for this reason I mean you'll see it
in a minute but I've been testing trust
me I have a phone with rap cyl and one
without and or one with a different uh
invisible shield on it
and you will see by the results I'm
about to show you guys that wraps toll
is definitely better than the
competition which I'm about to show you
guys so stay tuned rate 5 stars
so if you guys already watched my rap so
unboxing video you guys will have seen
all the stuff that rap cyl includes in
their box so when they ship you the rap
cyl for your device you'll get a lot
more than just the rap cyl itself 5
stars
you get your microfiber your spritz
bottle your solution application
instructions and the actual film and
that's just if you got it for your phone
I got it from my lg VX 10,000 you can
get yours for your your mobile phone
your mp3 player your ipod your laptop
your camera your xbox or ps3 five stars
no but seriously guys the rap cyl is
simply the best let me show you guys a
few images or a few video that I took
the first one is of the wraps all that I
had on one of my LG voyagers and this
one see how clean it is see how normal
it looks on the LG Voyager the nice
matte finish on the back it's perfect
for your grip for you it doesn't add any
look to the voyage or anything now look
at the second one this is the the
leading competitor if you will look at
how many air bubbles are on the front
side and look at how just it does not
look like the same phone on the back I
really don't like that but I love the
way rap soul incorporates what they do
with the matte finish on the back and
the anti gloss it's very very nice on
the front so that's that's why wraps is
simply the best right now they also ship
you a completely recyclable box which
you will be able to just get rid of
right when you're done applying the
wraps 'el all in all I have to say I
love the wrap salon my phone right now
announce that
one on my laptop and I also really like
the microfiber that they include so I'm
going to rate this from a hardware
review and nine and a half out of ten
that is the highest rating I've ever
given a hardware review so guys
seriously if you like what you see check
it out description and if you want to
enter the contest that they are holding
right now also throw their youtube link
in the description anyway that is
basically it thanks for watching guys
peace